agora
eu sou fotógrafo natureza há há há uma
década tem o privilégio de viver nestas
ilhas e de explorar alguns dos segredos
que este marketing officer e foi preciso
dessa década pelo realmente ter uma
noção do sítio especial que os açores
são em termos de riqueza e
biodiversidade marinha
é esta casa da luz mas todas essas
imagens que conseguem ver aqui foram
todas tratadas nas águas dos açores e eu
gostaria para cá convosco algumas das
pensões que tem passado neste mara e
também qual foi meu percurso para é ter
durado dez anos a descobrir realmente
citam tava viver é minha primeira visita
o arquipélago foi há 15 anos atrás
quando ainda era um estudante um jovem
estudante de direito e nessa altura
terei o meu primeiro curso de mergulho e
escuros mergulho ia acabar por mudaram
ea minha o curso profissional e minha
maneira de encarar a vida
quando acabei o curso de mergulho é a
primeira viagem do orgulho que fiz foi a
que hora que fala dos açores as ilhas
das flores e do corvo e foi realmente
uma experiência que marcou muito é
perceber que nós vivemos num país tinha
passagem dos brancos como estas que eram
quase inimagináveis para mim é e também
um marco no caso pelo homem e que pelo
menos comparado com as nossas águas do
continente é e portanto até o final do
meu curso de direito é viajei muito pelo
mundo mergulhar por exemplo na grande
barreira de coral da austrália nova
zelândia tailândia e vários motivos mas
quando cheguei ao final da licenciatura
é percebi que cada vez mais pensava nuno
que eu gostava de fazer era viver uma
vida em contato com o mar e o sítio que
tinha visitado mas não tinha mercado era
de facto das suas opções pareciam um
marco explorar o mar de oportunidades e
de espécies novas e de imprevisibilidade
cada vez que ia tomar
visão de abandonar a carreira da
advocacia e mudaram aqui para ponta
delgada onde acabei por ter muita sorte
rapidamente entrar no curso de biologia
marinha e como a ibm a trabalhar em
empresas observação dos passos e comecei
a viver as minhas primeiras aventuras no
mar nunca tinha visto uma bola na vida
nunca tinha visto o filme certo é e
realmente isso passou a fazer parte do
meu cotidiano e vier estas coisas
maravilhosas numa base diária e quando
mudar pois a sorte realmente o meu
objetivo era viver uma vida em contar
com marta mas trazia também um sonho e
esse sonho era um dia tornar um
fotógrafo de obra subiu 45 mas havia
dois obstáculos e um deles era que eu
não tinha nenhuma máquina de filmar nem
de fotografar e também nem seria provar
nem sabia informar mexe explora tanto o
objetivo de vida era mais um sony e não
tanto uma meta a atingir
é mas o meu dia a dia os golfinhos e
provocou as primeiras baleias
vou aqui eu começasse é olha a
fotografia como uma maneira de registrar
este momento é para poder mostrar aos
pais e os amigos a família e mostrar que
não estava enfiado no escritório de
advocacia mais ou menos estava a fazer
coisas muito interessantes e pelo menos
alívio ter muita é passar por essa
experiência
e esses 30 estive a trabalhar em
empresas na observação dos cetáceos
foram muito importantes para mim é e foi
um primeiro passo para descobrir
realmente vivia num sítio único a nível
mundial não poderia haver muitos títulos
a nível mundial
ou talvez quase um terço todas as
espécies de baleias e golfinhos que
existe em nosso planeta
e essa foi a minha o meu primeiro
contato é com o mundo fora d'água e
nesta altura ainda não tinha dinheiro
para comprar o material subaquático é
mas fui sempre insistindo ano uma
máquina que querem hora em uma lenta
melhora e evando que cada vez mais a
filosofia é sério e passado cerca de
três anos de saída do lote em tenha
poupado - eu sento e tem um equipamento
minimamente razoável para tirar algumas
fotografias e já tem algumas fotografias
com os quais não sentia de alguma
maneira satisfeito e passaram por
experiências incríveis como por exemplo
o ar com orcas baleias-azuis xuxa
quixote é uma em finados de diferentes
espécies
é neste mar de surpresas que o mar dos
açores e houve um dia que tava tomar um
café aqui em ponta delgada e o açoriano
oriental em uma pequena notícia dizia
que é um fotógrafo australiano chamado
red shoes tinha sido premiado vai
fotografar dinheiro quero mais
o maior e mais prestigiado concurso
fotografia de natureza a nível mundial e
que a fotografia como eu tinha sido
premiado tenha sido tirada nos açores
que esta pequena sofia aqui numa uma
baleia valley fina e realmente pensa eu
vou passar por experiências fantásticas
numa base diária é se calhar devia
tentar concorrer a este concurso e no
ano seguinte e com que com um como com
esta imagem que acabou por ser premiada
e não fazia idéia que nunca nenhum eu
tinha sido premiado no a fotógrafa
família ao longo da sua história e é uma
franquia do grupo docas foi tirar
provavelmente menos três quilômetros de
distância teatro entrada duas milhas da
costa que aceita a ponta delgada
realmente essa foi é minha grande
oportunidade para deixar todas as minhas
outras atividades e de karma tempo
inteiro numa carreira de fotógrafo
natureza
curiosamente no mesmo mês em que soube
que esse problema não vai fotografar
mineiro conseguiu publicar a minha
primeira história né na revista national
geographic portugal se viria a tornar
uma colaboração é regular
é esse o tema não podia ser mais um
santo e aumentou ainda mais um meu
fechine por estas ilhas
tratava-se do dogão bahia o maior país
do mundo e acontece que o tubarão-baleia
apesar do já muito tempo se ouve falar
de relatos de pescadores do atum do
chamado pintado com os pescadores não
sabem exatamente o que querem os
pintados mas eu não quero uma coisa
muito grande eu passei por baixo do
barco que normalmente trazia muitas um é
em agosto 2008 recebi um telefonema de
um amigo meu país de santa maria disse
que há um mês kanawa andar todos os dias
com tubarões baleia é santa maria
eu fiquei incrédulo com esta situação no
dia seguinte no avião é direto para
santa maria está em viagem
ingresso e teve que ficar lá até
conseguir uma imagem do maior país do
mundo e realmente esta foi a primeira
imagem conseguir as camas apenas um
barco de pesca do atum e um dos fiadores
disse que haviam pintado baixo do barco
e então entrei para dentro d'água e foi
esse o cenário que encontrei essa foi a
primeira vez que conseguirá é um tubarão
baleia com cerca de 10 metros
comprimento e talvez franzindo ea tons a
volta em alimentação eo mais curioso é
que mal é mulher para dentro d'água e
tim maia este gigante dos mares vai
directamente e peru é um metro de mim
boca aberta
olhar pra mim e realmente foi um cenário
único é cabeça preenchida regras um
gigante dos mares e e ela estava a
observar a mim conseguem vê-la em um
barco de pesca do atum é conseguir uma
cooperação com os credores votou e
durante uma semana teremos a retomar
hoje baleia todos os dias em cenários
fantásticos na passada mais uma situação
final enquanto eram malaias tentava
alimentar uma bola de chapa e bosh
chapinha sempre traz o tubarão baleia
para tentar não ser comida então
consegui algumas imagens deste ano e nos
anos seguintes foi sempre voltando à
ilha de santa maria para continuar esse
trabalho tentar trocar o tubarão baleia
e nos últimos três anos já com uma
equipa do tratamento a cmf pescas para
tentar colocar transmissor chantelle
custo vai rolar para tentar descobrir
porque com maior país do mundo é vem aos
açores e por que vai acompanhado
milhares de tudo é não fazer a mínima
ideia do next vai nem conexão itafoz do
maior país do mundo particularmente esta
imagem porque dá uma noção de escala do
que é o tamanho do tubarão baleia
vocês conseguem ver que ele é um
goleador do do meu trabalho e comparar
com o tubarão-baleia podem ver a noção
de escala que estudar e realmente nesse
momento eu percebi que nos açores havia
muito por descobrir havia muito que eu
poderia mostrar pela primeira vez é
outra história que marcou
significativamente a minha carreira
foi realmente eu tinha acabado de tomar
esta decisão tomar fotógrafo natureza
tempo inteiro e não sabe exatamente o
que conquistar os leitores a faixa nem
como é que vem das suas imagens nem nada
disse
então mandei um email é um fotógrafo
andré najaf internacional bastante
conhecido e eu conhecia e eu enviamos
uma resposta muito curta que deve ser
milhares de cartas e e mails vivo nos
títulos com o melhor case biodiversidade
a nível mundial e que é visitada pelos
nossos fotógrafos do mundo todos os anos
o que tem que fazer é centrar os seus
esforços nos açores esquecer o resto do
planeta porque o resto do planeta muitas
obras que vão visitar tenta mostrar os
açores como nunca foi visto aos
açorianos aos portugueses e ao mundo
realmente essas palavras marcaram e
poucos meses depois estava de barba é o
largo e muito próximo da costa da lagoa
e ela estava completamente o fabuloso
depois da cabeça fora d'água enquanto
hilton água e assim com as barbas
penduradas fora
em uma investida do espetáculo único que
viu uma barbatana do dorsal para ser um
tubarão fraco
o mais curioso é que eu mesmo tinha
vindo da escócia o melhor sítio do mundo
pode ser o fato de o esperado e está com
dizendo estou motivado e nunca tinha
conseguido ator fiuk eu queria um
tubarão curioso que viesse mesmo
diretamente boca aberta e que começa
pela boca aberta e mal aqui dentro
d'água eve que aumentavam tiveram um
fraco cerca de sete metros comprimento e
pedro mora cultural dentro d'água que
não só estava mais de 20 metros mesmo
estava sempre a alimentação boca aberta
mas assim que eu não consegui acompanhar
voltaram atrás e passaram a 50 cm para
consertar uma atrofia unhas por baixo do
mar que tivemos uma hora até problemas
luz do sol sempre interagir com este
verão eu só para ter uma idéia da escala
do animal o
o barco está por cima tem cinco metros
em maio a média que era um animal
bastante grande mas mais um gigante
curioso e ia seguir estas são
fotografias realmente cheguei à
conclusão que essas foram as primeiras
imagens registadas um tubarão frade nos
açores no seu meio natural imagens do do
tubarão baleia tamanho do do maior isso
maior parte do mundo está nas nossas
águas e que nós não sabemos se realmente
há tanto por descobrir nos açores que
fazer o mesmo todos os outros órgãos irá
julgá la para que se conquiste tudo tudo
mais e cada vez mais possuía mais que a
vida que nós temos aqui em tão boa ou
melhor do que todos esses times a nível
mundial
foi uma decisão que eu tomei há cinco
anos atrás
e nesses últimos cinco anos teve a
oportunidade de brilhar em todas as
ilhas do arquipélago incluindo a ilha do
corvo onde existe uma pequena reserva
voluntária criada pelos próprios
pescadores para preservar esta pequena
comunidade de meros sumeru amanhã 1
debaixo d'água é um é um animal
extremamente afável atrás nós um
mergulho inteiro parece um cão estava
com cerca de 10 metros num único barulho
neste local por um grupo de pescadores
decidiu que ia proteger uma pequena área
do tamanho de um campo de futebol para
que os moradores pudessem visitar a ilha
começa interest perante interação
infelizmente é o único sítio nos açores
onde podemos fazer isto realmente não
temos reservas para a prática do
mergulho nos açores é e quem falou isso
falou de uma série de dispensas que
passaram ao longo desta década desde de
informações la vida incríveis às vezes
com a presença de grandes razões no seu
interior os famosos montes submarinos
dos açores que são realmente o que torna
este destino especial que são é sítios
como grande profundidade às vezes mais
mil metros que vai até a superfície até
muito perto da superfície e que agregam
uma vida incrível é de r é grande
os joelhos ou com prisão está rodeado de
dezenas ou centenas milhares de de de
tons é no bairro precisa lhes ao largo
do faial a 45 milhões do faial e claro
nadar com grupos de curiosos de mantas
que nadam graciosamente a volta dos dois
mergulhadores e isso é projeto aproxima
muito curiosas é e que possa montar
maneira da superfície que até podemos só
como mágica como as barbatanas é
mergulhar com o mulher com ele é preciso
que isto pra casa é o campeão nacional
do mergulho livre maneira que eu tenha
mais facilidade mas qualquer pessoa
realmente importam menos deus nem que
seja nos portão próximo é e já para não
falar da manhã é maior espécie de manhã
a nível mundial manteve rocha existe na
nossa água pode ter até oito metros de
envergadura e claro é o ícone
os cachalotes que temos grupo dos
chamados grupos produtores é todo ano
nas nossas águas e que nos proporciona
momentos como estes de uma pequena cria
é brincar com uma fêmea adulta parecem
estar a brincar acompanhada e as
crianças são extremamente curiosa às
vezes até se aproximam tanto que torna
difícil pra falas
isto são só pequenos exemplos uma vez
não temos muito tempo do que queremos
ver no nosso mar e e já não falar dos
grupos de o franzino da alimentação
quando a uma bola visto em que os
tubarões golfinhos atom e aves todas
alimentar só mesmo tempo e é um é um
cenário único e mesmo o topo da cadeia
alimentar nos nossos dias no oceano das
orcas visitam todos os todos os anos é o
nosso arquipélago
curiosamente na mesma altura o maior
animal que alguma vez habitou nosso
planeta é visita também o nosso
arquipélago a bola azul que todos os
anos é visto aqui nos açores e claro as
tartarugas é ter uma experiência
concreta que nascem nas costas da
florida passou dez anos no circo
aquático aqui à volta das ilhas dos
açores
o mesmo é é a maior do mundo
é também é visto aqui nas nossas águas e
já para não falar de uma imensidão de
diferentes espécies de tubarões como
tubarões azuis é tubarão e macuco
tubarões martel tubarões das galápagos
são espécies nós podemos ver aqui mas
hoje infelizmente eu estava mesmo passar
aqui mais tempo com você é é falar nos
amando algumas aventuras já passei nas
nossas águas
é mas achei que não ia ter hipótese de o
fazer porque realmente é uma imensidão
espécie estamos a falar de um sítio com
mais 500 espécies país é mais de 20
espécies de baleias e golfinhos cinco
das sete espécies de tartarugas que
existem a nível mundial mas não era para
eles um pequeno filme é que acho que
mostra melhor do que as minhas palavras
o que é mergulhar aqui nos açores e que
estava tudo deixaram
não vai ter alguns gostam de ostentar o
português brincou bastante com os outros
e no mar do sul e goiás
uai